connais tu es un petit peu l'histoire de
lévis reculant après moi je connais pas
trop d'histoires même pas du tout les
soirs patronat ont tous dit oh non
à part qu' il y a eu un incendie ici
avant par exemple nous avons et les
sélections du sud avec lui mine à sophie
et tout à coup c'était une étape qui
était présente lors de
l'insurrection quelque chose comme ça
c'était une dame
[Applaudissements]
c'est une dame mais avec quel est ton
avis qu'on connaît et je pense qu'elle
avait 60 ans maximum
nous sommes des élèves de 3e du collège
de new york une autre mais que
connaissons-nous de notre commune
pas grand chose nous avons tous réalisé
qu'une connexion ni l'histoire ni les
événements marquants de nos pilotes
alors nous avons décidé d'aller à la
rencontre de cette histoire nous sommes
d'abord bondi à la bibliothèque
municipale pour questionner hervé une
option mais quel est l'événement qui a
marqué les esprits en 1970 ici les
femmes incendie du 24 février 1970 alors
j'étais tout près j'étais enfant je me
trouvais en classe de 6ème et j'ai vu
les premières flammes alors la légende
dit que c'est 100 ans après
l'insurrection du sud de dire que
c'était une espèce de révolte qui s'est
produit 22 ans après l'abolition de
l'esclavagé de 1848 1870 il ya eu cette
révolte pour plus de justice plus de
dignité
noyer
tin oo
hawaï
hacher le jeu
[Musique]
alors des gens parlaient de la sphère
codé la sphère cours des vingt six
propriétaires pour qu'ils y étaient le
musée de la monnaie qui fait l'europe
est un l'un des propriétaires qui même
après l'abolition des esclavages
continuer à pratiquer l'esclavagé
suscitèrent on considère le noir comme
du bétail toujours toujours il n'a pas
le droit de se déplacer il faut qu'ils
aient un passeport et terminale et
combat mais les insurgés avaient des
instituteurs des gens qui étaient
commencés à être cultivé ils se sont
réunis les informations venaient de
partout ils se sont dit que c'est pas
normal qu'on pratique ce genre de
discrimination
je vous connais pas d'enfant
s'il ya une version actualisée du sud de
ce qu'il ya une belle sophie à une
madeleine clem etc mais oublie que les
choses dans l'aude
je connais pas grand chose j'ai entendu
vaguement parlé de l'umih n'a sophie par
contre je suis très mal placé pour faire
tout en cours sur elle
mais entre autres je sais que beaucoup
de bâtiments portent son nom
quand j'étais à l'école n'a pas probable
en classe il sait se sont rassemblés
lundi nous est web bien près où les
hommes il y avait des chefs cinq chefs
est l'une des chefs les plus terribles
c'était lui mine à sophie était la plus
jeune mais elle était la plus rapide la
plus téméraire la plus hardie lumine à
sophie physiquement les machines grande
noir avec un bouddha frau un belle afro
qu'elle ait un visage sauvage qui
montrent qu'elle ait du caractère je
pense qu'elle avait peut-être dans la
trentaine et
voilà est très mal à ces jeunes dans la
vingtaine entre 22 et 25 ans si c'était
une cloche je pense que tu fais un
flamboyant c'est les tuer l'animal
je pense qu est ce qu ils violent si
c'était une qualité je pense qu'elle
fait ouais je pense qu'elle était déjà
principaux après je pense qu'elle était
peut-être joufflu je pense que ça va
être une femme mais une femme noire
une jolie fun c'est tout chartres où
elle était jolie de kaka je parle je
pense qu'elle était assise belle quand
même parce que je me dis que ça génial
son père qui devait être vêtu de madran
la tamise qualifier les martiniquaises
et
je pense qu'elle avait les cheveux
crépus les cheveux peut-être beaucoup de
cheveux visage rond si elle était une
gosse elle sera le baylet dans son
regard
on pouvait aussi desclaux une finale
plus mais aussi une âme résistante qui
avait de la valeur si je veux être comme
un animal ou divers nhuân un cruel parce
qu'elle avait un fort caractère et ça
avait dû se défendre
aller jusqu'au bout et si elle gamme
mener les troupes
donc elle avait les ont donné le feu
vert le 22 septembre 1870 ils ont été
brûlées toutes les habitations alias
aller à cet esprit à jour sur à la
monnaie c'était là et après six jours il
n'y avait pas d'armes il avait que des
pics des toges les flambeaux les
couteaux face à la marée chaussée
vous avez des fusils des deux
mousquetons à l'époque ils ont maté la
révolte le 30 septembre et lumineux
sophie on l'a condamné aux travaux
forcés au bagne de cayenne
tenez vous bien laver 19 ans
en plus elle était enceinte
comme elle ne mangeait pas correctement
n'est pas de vitamines elle n'avait pas
ce qu'il fallait
l'enfant décède quelques mois après donc
là on n'avait même pas un an ce qui fait
que la descente dans un limina sophie
n'existe pas le 15 décembre 1879 lumine
à sophie décède à 4 heures de l'après
midi à saint laurent du maroni
elle est âgée de 31 ans
il
[Musique]
m
à la base de couturière est ce vraiment
tout faire l'indépendance et puissante
elle était vraiment été en
[Musique]
ma famille
femmes 1
[Musique]
mais les 110 j'avais 11 ans c'est sûr
que rémy et jean qui dépassait ma tête
il fallait courir quand on a vu les
flammes
on est allé se réfugier sur les hauteurs
de ia pilotes parce qu'on n'arrivait pas
à éteindre les flammes depuis 10 heures
du matin il était 15 heures
l'après midi il ya eu plus de 50 maisons
qui ont disparu dans les flammes
y a pas eu loisir de victimes mais c'est
m
grand incendie qui a fait parler pendant
des dizaines d'années
j'ai une espèce mue de fumée noire et
prenez part tout aussi d'il ya quelque
chose qui s'est passé mais la ville
stations-service des sauces là où le
marché est sur le coup trois du marché
facile vitesse face aux services et à
des petits commerces là se trouve la
pharmacie qui lance maintenant le fait
part de la hes-so embrasé tout le monde
partout et c'était les gens pour perdu
en poule et le merveilleux tout perdu
tout perdu et c'était vraiment aller
voir ça c'était comment dire
l'apocalypse est uni de l'histoire ou
encore comme on dit fait magique
homonyme est-ce que c'est magique
est-ce que ça devait arriver enfin les
gens s'interroge est-ce qu'ils ont un
côté magique qu'est ce que les âmes des
gens qui sont pas morts ou qui n'a pas
une cérémonie religieuse pour eux se
sont pas réveillés pour montrer que cet
incendie la nie pas prête à s'éteindre
ça c'est une autre interprétation puis
la dernière interprétation si les gens
disent que le blanc qu'on a tué sur la
propriété de money le propriétaire de la
money codé qui est venu incendié le
boudeur il ya pilotes
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la légende
révolte révolte des voltes révolte
révolte révolte les volts et volt
révolte révolte révolte révolte révolte
des volts
je pense que ce qui peu révolté les
jeunes se laissent les discriminations
parce que les jeux discrimine beaucoup
surtout quand les jeunes cons et plus ça
passe mais voilà qu'on est jeune et je
suis beaucoup plus méchant puisque ce
sont des enfants ils se hissent euros
tiennent pas par exemple les gens qui
par exemple des difficultés ou les gens
qu'ils ont qui ne sont pas pareils
physiquement ou les origines ou la
religion ou les trucs de ce genre
et le physique je sais pas des choses
comme ça moi c'est la pollution
parce que comme les gens faux nul les
personnes polluent la nature et donc en
fait ça à faire les changements
climatiques et donc qu'il ya des îles
qui qui sont qui vont bientôt
disparaître les espèces en voie de
disparition
le braconnage tout ça les pandas qui
sont tués
les animaux qui sont tués pour leur peau
tout ça pour leur chair pour la violer
j'aime bien les animaux
bah quand j'en entends parler ça me
révolte beaucoup quoi surtout que plus
tard j'aimerais soigneurs animaliers
donc quand j'entends des choses comme ça
ça me choque
alors là c'est parce que ça qui arrive à
tuer les gens
les critiques aussi les stigmates et
puis les mauvaises langues le racisme
les sites
ou aussi au niveau de l'emploi quand il
ya les illégalités envers femmes hommes
où selon la religion à la boue juifs
cissé envers nous enfin nous personnes
de couleur oui peut-être que je
travaille beaucoup et bien la
discrimination positive
sachez une chose que j'aime pas du
[Musique]
you win ma ma mère pour hewitt
ayew
à commencer dès l'aube il a un côté nous
semblait me berthe
mais autant c
oui
oui à vue
j'écoutais
je vais
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grâce à sa chute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]